maybe we're all becoming like genderless
you know babies and test tubes
i don't think so i mean i think i think
society is changing in a way that
encourages certain behaviors and stuff
but
testosterone plays a role man
in a lot of things
i think people are getting sicker and
that's part of the problem interesting
like i think that if you're on i mean i
don't know what percentage of the
population is on some sort of like psych
med at the moment or on
yeah and since covet has gotten worse
and those things have like they make
people different than they are so i
think people like obviously people are
getting sick one in five people have an
autoimmune disorder people are gaining
weight like mad and i think that comes
with mental problems and i think that
screws up your behavior including
probably the more normal
like feminine and masculine behavior